في حلقه امس ما قلنا لكم كمان مستجدات
قضيه البلوجر المصريه هدير عاطف المحبوس
على ذمه التحقيقات هي وتليقها واخته
وزوجها بتهمه النصب والاحتيال من بعد 16
بلاغ تقدموا للسلطات بانهم اخذوا منهم
فلوس للاستثمار وما اعطوهم ارباح ولا
ارجعوا اي فلوس او مكاسب في حلقه امس
نقلنا اعترافات طريق هدير اللي توافقت مع
روايه اهلها وهي انه هدير ما كانت تعرف
شيء عن النشاط ابدا وانها لمن عرفت طلبت
الطلاق وانفصلت بالفعل الجديد اللي نقلته
وسائل الاعلام المصريه هو اعترافات هذه
نفسها هدير نفذ تماما علمها بممارسه
الطريقه وقالت انها عرفت لما بدات توصلها
مسجات من ناس بتقول لها رجع فلوسنا وصلها
كثير كمان تهديدات وهنا واجهته واتخانقت
معه وطلبت الطلاق
وقالت لي النيابه انها قطعت كل علاقتها
بالتجاره هذه كمان اقرت للنيابه انه فعلا
بها البنكي كان بيستخدم وجلس بيك
وبيستخدموا زوجها وبينزل فيه فلوس بس كان
قايل لها ان هو مضطر يعمل كده لانه حسابه
محظور من كثر الايداع فيك طيب واكدت كمان
انه ما كانت تعرف انه بيتاجر في العملات
الرقميه المحظوره في مصر وقالت انه بلال
كان بيستغل شهرتها اشغلو وعلشان يعمل
ارتفاعات وهمم يوقع به ضحايا محامي هذه
طلب من النيابه كمان السماح لهدير بارضاع
بنتها اللي عندها ثقب في القلب والنيابه
سمحت لها بدايه
[موسيقى]